صوت شائع في المطابخ حول
العالم زيت طهي ساخن على
مدار العام ، يستهلك الإنسان
العادي حوالي 20 كيلوجرامًا من
الزيت النباتي في مصر ، وهذا الرقم
أعلى من ذلك ، وبمجرد استخدامه ، يتم التخلص من معظمه
ولكن ليس
لدي دائمًا هذه النفايات المنتجة
الآن لدي  لمعرفة ما يجب فعله بهذا
الزيت في عام 2013 ، أنشأت نورلا سال تاغادوت
شركة ناشئة مقرها القاهرة تعيد تدوير
زيت الطهي المستخدم لإنتاج الوقود الحيوي ، وهو
مصدر بديل للطاقة منخفض الكربون
هذا العام ، قررت نور النظر في المزيد
من الطرق لتبسيط المجموعة.  في
المنزل ،
نقوم بتمكين جمع النفايات من خلال
التكنولوجيا من
خلال إنشاء منصة شبيهة بأوبر
والتي تربط الجامعين مع المنازل
عند الانتهاء من القلي ، يستغرق الأمر بضع
نقرات على التطبيق للحصول على جامع
ليأتي ويلتقط الزيت المستخدم
الذي يحصل عليه العميل أيضًا  شيء في
المقابل مثل زجاجات زيت الطهي الجديد
الجاهزة لوجبتهم التالية مما يجعل
النظام أكثر ربحية وصديقًا للبيئة
أيضًا
ess آلاف الطلبات على
أساس يومي وهذه تحدث بشكل أساسي
عبر
أجزاء مختلفة من مصر ،
لذلك نعتقد أن هناك تأثيرًا
كبيرًا يتم إجراؤه على المستوى البيئي
يمكن استخدام الوقود الحيوي
كبديل للبنزين في السيارات ووسائل
النقل الأخرى بأكثر من 10 ملايين
المركبات على الطريق في مصر ،
يمكن أن يؤدي جمع نفايات الزيوت بكفاءة
إلى اعتماد أكبر للوقود الحيوي ،
وأعتقد أن الوقود الحيوي يمكن استخدامه هنا في
مصر في المستقبل القريب جدًا
لتقليل انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري بشكل أساسي
لتكون قادرًا على أن تكون جزءًا
من  تخطط حركة تغير المناخ
في الوقت الحالي لتوسيع نطاق
أعماله عبر الشرق الأوسط
وشمال إفريقيا
على أمل أن يفرز عدد أقل من الناس
فكرته عن مستقبل أكثر خضرة في
الهاوية آنا ستيوارت CNN